ce sont aujourd'hui plus de 50 km de
terre arménienne qui sont occupés par
les soldats azerbaïanés il s'agit là non
seulement d'une relation du CCF de 2020
mais également de l'intégrité
territoriale d'un état rappelons-le
souverain l'Arménie déplore aujourd'hui
des centaines de morts civiles
militaires des blessés des milliers de
déplacés et que dire de ce patrimoine
universel mondial qui depuis deux ans et
saccagé pour être effacé alors oui la
communauté internationale CMU mais c'est
abstenu d'agir
sans doute témoignant d'un fort embarras
et puis bien sûr légitimement préoccupé
par le conflit en Ukraine le silence de
la communauté internationale de la
Communauté européenne et de la France
est assourdissant sur le sort de
l'Arménie cette semaine a circulé une
vidéo malheureusement authentifiée
montrant des soldats Arméniens lâchement
tués par des soldats à zéro et
aujourd'hui la Communauté européenne
demande à baïku les bourreaux eux-mêmes
de diligenter une enquête alors avec le
groupe les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale nous demandons solennellement
à Emmanuel Macron de faire entendre haut
et fort la voix de la France qui nous
avec l'Arménie des liens d'amitié
séculaire de demander qu'une enquête
internationale soit menée pour vérifier
ces crimes de guerre potentielles de
mobiliser les partenaires internationaux
et les ONU afin que soient données tous
les moyens à l'Arménie de protéger son
peuple et que soit mis fin
définitivement à ce conflit